this week conflict zone is in Brussels
as the European Union struggles to find
an answer to populism my guest is
Manfred vapour leader of the
center-right European People's Party as
the word adapts to the prospects of
Donald Trump as US president and an EU
without written what is his vision for
the future of the European Union
nonfat vapor welcome to conflict zone
let's start with the latest developments
in the United States the election of
Donald Trump has been especially
welcomed by far-right parties across
Europe are you worried well I'm
concerned because uncertainty is what is
ahead of us and on the other hand we
have to respect the outcome it was a
democratic I didn't ask if you have to
respect the election I asked if you are
worried about the result of the election
I mean a right-wing populists and as I'm
concerned yes especially about the
uncertainty again it's important to see
it's a democratic vote so we have to say
first of all welcome to the new
president but we have to say this honest
on the position of strength so Europe
has to be has to be strong in an answer
to the Americans that is what the photo
marine lepen is also welcoming the new
president from the french national the
stance of a good chance of winning
presidency is growing she says it's a
global movement what happened in America
a global movement determined by racism
nationalism and sexism we are talking
about France one of the pillars of the
European Union that's why we as
Europeans you have to stand up you have
to defend our European Way of life not
to copy the American Way of life to our
European Way of life the Indian started
the engine started not the Americans i
miss hungary you saw Emily a development
you see globally a development that
people are afraid about the future
globalization digitalization everything
went so far people are concerned about
what does it mean for my life for my
identity even and this are interviewed
miles figures you really have elections
yeah and then we have to fight that's a
democracy no it's not up to us as a
leads as politicians as genre studies
that is up to people to decide but we
have to say clearly what this means to
vote for populists simple for extremists
I guess you mean I can show it on the on
the on the European Parliament because
people voted for marine lepen people
voted for builders people voted for four
struck in Austria they have no influence
in any kind of decision making process
and European level
because populous and extremists have no
idea what they are in favor they are you
talking about they all burn from Hungary
are you talking about the Prime Minister
folan extremist nationalist racist or
not Viktor Orban a cut from in the last
mandate from Barroso and from Viviane
Reding a lot of remarks on his
legislation on media on the question of
asians a constitutional law inside of
Hungary and Orban delivered on all these
remark in Poland from Poland not cut
jeans cannot fall so you can see the
difference the right-wing parties are
not anymore theory they are governing in
countries in the European Union the
other hand we have eighty percent of
support in Poland for the European Union
so I think concoctions what is more
important I to leave the government or
to hide everything all which is in
Iceland I think Kosinski can not go
along this way for a long time that is
why that is why we have to we aren't
really in the fundament his nightmare so
BEC thing what the European Parliament
the Commission is saying and doing about
his decisions let's say about the High
Court about the right of prayer is why I
would appeal to the member states that
you cannot did say the European
Commission should defend our values I
would ask in the European Council to do
a debate about Poland why is in the
European Council an angle America
Hollande may our tree meeting each other
why is your not a debate about what is
Khmer is not being any long time is this
club that is that I regret but but but
she still there and the idea is simply
some of the politicians in Europe think
that you can use Brussels for the bad
not stories for the bad things and you
can do at national level the positive
things also as party leader herself upon
the CSU likes to play this game
sometimes all the national politicians
are trying to play this case somebody is
also very happy about the result of the
election America is health illness of
the Dutch party of freedom has called
these result the patch for patriotic
spring he too has a high chance of
winning the upcoming elections in the
Netherlands once a liberal and tolerant
society what is going on in Europe first
I don't accept that we copy ville de
slip n miss Trump's that is not correct
Trump at the same electoral it
like for example last time Mitt Romney
had the desert head so there is not
there is not to take copy and paste it
and he is slaughter aunty aunty refugees
national if mrs. Jenness I don't accept
this computer is in bits of his Trump
and the pen is not the same and on the
other Smurfs and on the other i just
worse I think I pennis as extreme it's
extremist when she wants to destroy the
euro and she wants to destroy Chang and
Eng wants to destroy our fundament of
the European she's worse there
absolutely but let me say what is what
we'd have to learn out of this
development what we have to learn this
there is not any more acceptable in the
European Union to declare some of the
issues with people are concerned about
as politically uncorrect that we are not
allowed to talk about issues for example
then people are afraid let's have been
cranking speaking frankly speaking when
my party or when the PP party
european-wide said last year that it's
immigration the unity migrations your
opinion is too much then we had a lot of
criticism from Charlottesville photos
normal you have an opinion that is
there's another pinion I mean still
allowed to say whatever you enjoyed be
sure your victim we showed our position
and I think that's okay and that is ok
so where is where I find the point is
that we have really the people see that
the elites in a way that silly were the
elites the people you are I'm also
Eligius that's why we have to rethink
our position and my position is that we
have to talk about the concerns of the
people that is what is talking about the
concerns the AFT in Germany you have the
extra missed in every country of the
european union and they are talking very
loudly were is the problem yeah the
problem is that we had in a lot of
member states a debate that the public
opinion which was created but a lot of
friends was not covered by the opinion
of the people that is what i want to say
look at again but again the more
important thing is to clarify my
position one is to talk about the issues
people are concerned and we have to pick
up the concerns and the second thing is
that we should not cross the red line of
populism if EPP is my body the European
People's Party beers as strong as
gruben's ourselves we are the strongest
political family all over Europe if we
try to copy populism then we will do we
would do a big mistake because then we
would even strengthen populism but I
have been deceived
after this you and let's be honest a
truly successful weapon against populism
has not come to your mind yet but what
are you doing there I think there are
examples you have to look on them for
example in Croatia small country okay
but an important country of the European
Union a colleague of mine one as prime
minister in the last election campaign
without doing campaign against Serbs
against this nationalism and so on and
he won the election is a clear
pro-european approach so there are
signals that we will do this my party
took over in the last year's
responsibility we were the party of
austerity in Spain in Portugal in Greece
with some of us in Ireland with Enda
Kenny we did the job of reforming the
countries in the european union and i
have to say we are still the biggest and
largest political family so that people
expect today leadership that is what we
have to do but taking our picking up
means the people are expecting
leadership can we speak about the issues
the kanye absolutely lesser what are the
content the contents are for example
having Trump in mind that we have to do
more in defense since your opinion and
that is very concrete point and that is
what does it mean in a European army
that is probably the long-term approach
but I would ask to do very pragmatic
concrete steps for example in cyber war
to defend ourselves and suburb for
example on drones to invest together in
drones which one single country cannot
do it alone anymore but when I was
thinking about security the security
issue the question also how are we
defending the borders here again are we
speaking about European army the
European army is for me a long term
approach because I'm not a short-term
Miami gonna be ethical crisis as borders
and if you ask about water control
border control is not army it's about
water security there's are other forces
we have to investor and their Europe did
a great step after the cows of last year
in the in the in the European Union we
invested in the front X and today in
bulgaria on the border region jet to
Turkey we have European forces the sicu
mom is a possibility to take over the
command in force and they are doing the
chop their new Europe is getting step
and step I mean that's one mr. Trump
said that his involvement in the NATO is
not anymore the first prior
RT is Europe has rules and algae
relative to create that everybody has to
contribute and I think this is one of
the few points where Donald Trump is
right because when you see the
investments of America in our NATO
security system and when you see the
investments of our taxpayers in the
European Union then it's a fair point
that the Americans say they are only
repaying for the security there is a
fair point and that's why we have to
invest and Maya manages my soldiers
money money not first of all money is
because we are spending a lot of money
in the European Union in defense the
question is the efficiency how good we
are investing and I would appeal if we
do this more together we would use the
taxpayers money in a more efficiently
let's go back to Germany and your
country Bavaria you are a member of the
Conservative CSU 30 years ago one of
your parties most famously those fancy
of styles declared there can be no
democratically legitimated party to the
right of the CSU is that not true
anymore that is true and that's why the
this year's remember where we r zp b
generally are fighting against populism
you know that bavaria did in the refugee
crisis an enormous enormous search of
people volunteers did enormous chop in
bavaria c state is investing a lot so we
are helping people in need but on the
other thing side we are thing so
everything has limits everything has
limits and both sides only voted let's
be honest yeah there is such a party in
Germany and the name is a FDA and you
and your party are rather scared of it
it seems that the concept also from the
CSU in order to fight right wing parties
is to imitate them you do know that in
the end people are voting for the
original nobody's copying them again but
we are picking up the issues of the
people and if you are doing to this
interesting aft and we are described we
had already twenty years ago the
Republicans in Bavaria who were also
rightwing extremists and V eliminated
them so we'd fought against them and you
have you as accessible as yes several
countries Germany
a good chance there is a good evening
won more votes than see you there is a
good chance to really fight against them
if we do this together and with account
a concept which people can understand
and it's a middle way it's a middle way
between helping people in need Syrians
seeing the tragedy of Aleppo everybody
must be helped Master man must won't
help them and on the other hand we have
to say it's about limits we have we
cannot take over everybody on this
global level last autumn Anita that's
why all well we had last year is a
duration to open the border and I'm from
pasa I'm from the border region to
Austria that's my constituency and there
was no check anymore nobody asked
whether you are from Afghanistan from
Namibia or from Syria we had only opened
our borders and that is not a good
approach your party leader Jose office
says like you are just mentioning angle
America's refugee policy is to blame for
the success of the AFD do you agree with
this the refugee crisis in the last
years is a fundamental politically
fundament for the strengths of the AFT
today that is correct and then july
party leader Allah Silva says angle
America's refugee policy is responsible
for that do you agree I think see Angela
Merkel approach last year was at the
starting a very good approach to show
the positive side of you know i will ask
another time to show to show what can i
say it is she responsible for the AFD or
not i think it was not a good decision
it would have had been not a good
decision to say we closed the border
immediately after her seeing the
Hungarian problems that's why the
humanitarian approach is good and we
have to defend this ICC's european-wide
I say this to my friends in polio you
will have rising in Oran angery was
right I say this too weak to openness
value has a mis also to us say who
helped again bavaria bavaria did a great
job through the last is damp ever you
need no lesson for nobody from nobody to
help loveria is giving lessons to angle
a miracle ha Zilpha checked a lawsuit
again marital for the breach of law he
accused her permanently to have things
let's go out of control and a dozen
danger germany that so as a otha didn't
blame erica for the success of the AFT
she's responsible
very critically and and and important is
the discussion last year but today I
have to say we have everything again
under control so the Balkan route is
closed we have now refugees where we
check all the Syrians who can stay or
all the legal immigrants who have to
leave that is what we are doing now in
Germany and there is now good and
balanced approach answer your census we
will defend this in the next chairman
elections but again on European level
it's the same we have to find a way to
define the Solidarity question in the
european union that is our open wound in
the european regular don't end in
european union and that's one of the
problems of germany and that's one of
the problems of the refugee crisis also
in Germany you don't have solidarity
people are not very happy about that
what good is acting and that's why we
have to work on this what is the problem
you show not least you're doing great
job to describe problems i'm a
politician's is the progression is a
time question I mean still today Aleppo
is in danger it still today refugees are
coming try to to survive so it's not a
theoretical question we are talking
about and still the European Union is
not working they took decisions but they
don't just respect their own decisions
at the European Union is working today
in a much more better way for example we
are giving much more money to the
refugee camps in the area in the region
to Turkey to children and to Lebanon we
are financing at the moment the
education of caesarean young children in
the camps not to be not to become
Islamist for example so we are doing a
lot I only appeal not to say everything
in a negative way we have still work to
do is literally we don't want to have
anything on the negative way but a lot
of negative our minds yes your party is
concerned about the influx of refugees
particularly when they have different
cultural backgrounds like Muslims from
Turkey and Arab states why well on again
on refugees of people who really needs
protection they have we have to talk
about the burden sharing miss turkey
with shadow of its service Lebanon and
then the other card yes and that is what
we have to do I insist in this we have
to take over responsibility a policy of
border closing of I don't care
is not acceptable for the European Union
we have to take over responsibility but
everything again with limits that is
what people are concerned about do we
only open borders and accept everybody
without control or do we have limits
there and to bring these two things
together how disassembly on that Europe
and Germany and specially Bavaria is a
Christian country is the problem that
the refugees are Muslims and not
Christians because this is what or
silver saying we don't want many Muslims
who are coming into our country's Alban
is saying the same the Polish government
is saying the same but the destiny is
doing what the Destiny is doing the
refugees are Muslims on a silver it's
not it's not correct because we received
I can say it again hundreds of thousands
of Muslims in Bavaria as refugees and
they are well protected and they have
everything what they need but we are
talking for example a very happy that
they are coming absolutely there is a
strong support in the Bavarian society
and we have fifty percent of voters in
Bavaria there is strong support of them
to want to help people in need we are a
strong country economically it working
well that's why there is the atmosphere
of I want to help and that is what I
expect from all the members in the
European Union that they have to share a
little bit they have to help others on
the other side side again limits let's
combine both things together and then
it's successful though they can fight
against always we have to combine
something else in the European
Parliament because just last week the
current President of the European
Parliament mr. Martin Schulz announced
that he was going back to politics to
Germany you have an agreement with a
socialist group to which he belongs that
the next president will be from the
European People's Party you are leading
are you going to run for this position
and don't tell me that you don't know if
you are doing that I have not seen
intention to run this president of
European Parliament and then we'll find
as you are not running yes you're not
you will not be the candidate we will
present on the twelfth of December
convincing candidate on behalf of the
plot it would not be manvi that will be
and it will be a candidate where we can
talk afterwards mrs. socialists to find
a common understanding because what i
want to secure what i want to guarantee
is that is european parliament
is it led by the pro-european democratic
forces I don't want to have any
influence of lepen and other extremists
on on personal staff issues and all
these things and on and on content I
apologize but I really didn't understand
it to the end ah and will you be a
candidate yes or no I have not the
intention to be a candidate that is the
reality let's talk about European
Commissioner Gunther Oettinger he
recently gave a speech in Hamburg
peppered with racist sexist and
homophobic remarks he didn't he didn't I
I listen to that I never did how'd he
carry for what did he say about Chinese
what it said about homosexuals and the
marriage if this is not a problem what
is a problem that is again the question
of political correctness you see if
somebody want if somebody's choking then
you are then you are saying it's racism
I don't declare this is this is a
question of political correctness
everything i described the Chinese as
Lydia I'd and as chiselers and you don't
think that this is a problem this is
only a problem about political
correctness at Exeter Chinese taxi
driver told me these are only these kids
discussions you can have in Europe not a
taxi driver is no is all your excuses no
peace Lord about open feels like usually
now I only describing said in China they
are making jokes about Europeans about
this appreciate that is not it is a ruin
all those not a mission or it's not any
more accepted to make any kind of choked
that is also a model you can live in I
don't want to live in such a world I
think if we bring things with a back to
the ground interesting it did the last
seven and a half years don't rate is
making about that is a chop as
commissioner for the European Union but
this is the excellence you'll ever do a
lot I don't look for excuse because I
don't see a problem you know you don't
see problem he also made fun of women
and potential mandatory gay marriage you
don't think that this is a problem I
don't think so because he did it in the
context of a choke if you want to do it
as an as an azimuth you have to do it as
a scandal it's your job I don't see it
in this way and that's why for me it's
converting is doing a great job as as
commissioner let's talk about another
issue the european parliament voted to
freeze membership talks with turkey with
your voice the turkish President other
one is blackmailing the European Union
by threatening to open the borders if
the Europeans do not do as he wants
isn't it isn't he that other issues
people are interested in okay so we know
what if I would be a Chinese and if I
would be gay I would be also interested
about what a commissioner is saying
about my groups or not I understand this
and he terrified things so that's let's
talk about I think otherwise let's talk
about it on and on the other hand the
question is that seeing the development
in Turkey its are acceptable for us and
Turkish pro-european groups the Turkish
pro-democracy groups are asking for a
signal of Europe even inside of the
country's I need support for their way
to defend the rule of no principle in
Turkey that's why I think the decision
of European Parliament was a good one a
very broad accepted one so by a lot of
groups to say full stop enough is enough
please turn around and go back that's
one side the other side is other one and
he threatened quote listen to me he's
speaking also to us to me listen to me
if you go any further then the frontiers
will be open bear that in mind this is
blackmail yeah the question is how
Europe is answering system I on thur
would be that the turkey needs Europe
much more did we need turkey why because
I have any final graphic and if not do
you have a plan if he goes ahead with
his threat I would say we have a plan
but the implementation awesome nobody
knows about it no border we did a lot i
already said it into me in the indian
tea in zee show that that he invested a
lot of the border protection but it's
too slow i underlined this again we have
to do more on the question of Border
Protection to defend our European
borders in a way not to close them but
to check who is arriving on the border
and again why is there was so much under
pressure I have to say the demographic
problem is in Turkey's the biggest
challenge he has to guarantee chops for
the young generation you have I need
economy have a plan if he does what he
said
sending 100,000 refugees to Greece what
is your reaction on that what is your
plan what can you do again or can he say
I send refugees he has to work together
with smugglers it's mafia is he
willingly is able to do this I don't
think so on the other hand the balcony
will disclose much done in close the
boat itself once you go alone then and
if you have a great problem you have to
practice solidarity with Greece that's
clearly have cannot let greets alone in
such a situation and that is East can't
afford that we we know about that
another 25 40 50 thousand couldn't work
why can not a continent with 500 million
inhabitants the biggest economist hunger
level asked polling no class clove
akhiya ask the others you have the
answer in this question after question
if there is a bill and the sea growing
bill then we have to do it together that
is the only alternative you know i'm a
pretty european politician i can you
give i can only share with you the
european answer if member states don't
want to have a strong European Union
than Europe is is weak if turkey does
open the floodgates the right-wing
populist will win the important
elections this year next year in France
in the Netherlands not even miracle
stands a chance how does it feel that l1
could massively influence the respective
national elections in Europe well we saw
in America that Russia can even
influence American the elections so we
are living in a globalized world that
you have this is the answer the answer
is this there is an impact there is a
there is a power from external powers
yes the question is always strong in us
to defend our interests are you yo you
Russell is ready to do so I want to the
other line this again not not the
leaders of the countries we are failing
at the moment with the National egoism
which we are facing most of the journey
was sometimes as well German one because
it would have fit been more about much
more better to ask before we opened our
borders last year to ask the others
whether they want to join as they will
do this together handle everybody should
step back and should say let's do it
together than your poem hand on your
heart do you even going to exist in five
years times I'm said yes times
absolutely as it is now as it is now
even stronger with the same members
having in mind that 25
years ago we had the economic crisis in
Europe we have still an economic crisis
Ehlinger it's still a big day along via
today stronger via today sweetie great
britain laughs having the exit france
having election you will see that the
brexit will lead at the end to a
situation where people understands how
important this union is because today
not Berlin and Paris as a problem is
proxied London has a big problem is the
preferred favor thanks very much for
being on conflicts i think it was
pleasure
you
you